hey i'm kevin and i'm sarah and there
are new episodes of draw off on the way
but today we're going to try something a
little bit different we're going to draw
the same thing
three times in two hours 20 minutes and
two minutes this is a challenge you've
seen all over youtube but today we're
going to do it a little bit different
i'm going to be drawing digitally and
i'll be drawing
traditionally the old-fashioned way the
way our forefathers
and what we're going to draw is a scene
from jrr tolkien's the hobbit it's a
scene in which bilbo steals a golden cup
from the dragon smog sarah you ready uh
you know uh it's a lot of pressure
um i'm gonna try my best
all right here we go two hours ready
okay yeah
and go so what are you drawing with
um they're prisma colors and they're
soft they blend nicely
cool i am drawing digitally
on a wacom cintiq and and i'm drawing in
adobe photoshop
so sarah you don't draw digitally much
do you
no i pretty much never draw digitally
um just because like i look at a screen
all day for work and then like you know
when i come home
it's like i like to not look at a screen
and i also for me drawing a lot of it is
um
about being tactile and like feeling
things and like carving things
out with my my utensils so i don't
really get the same sensation
from digital drawing but i think it's
cool
i'm not good at it people aren't good at
it i'm very impressed by i'm just not
one of them
i think i've worked out a nice
composition
nice sarah we are at the halfway point
how are you doing
um i'm like okay
it's just really difficult because i do
usually
spend hours and hours and hours on my
drawing
so it's really really hard to like
achieve something i'm happy with in just
two hours
sure yeah how about you
i'm i'm definitely there too i
i took way too much time sketching and
figuring out my composition and now i
feel like i'm behind
and so now i'm kind of rushing to to
catch up
i got my build my bilbo's pretty much
good i'm not super happy with him but
bilbo's done i just finished inking my
bilbo
and now i'm moving on to inking my
smog and the nice thing
about working in photoshop is that i can
separate
everything onto layers so when i want to
work on my smog i can literally
turn off my bilbo and just focus on smog
well must be nice
i'm like not feeling amazing about this
um i don't know i'm just
you know i have a high standard for
myself
there's nothing wrong with having a high
standard so you keep having that high
standard
and you keep working thanks kev
thanks you're welcome
all right sarah home stretch here how
you doing i'm ready for a nap
[Applause]
i will i'm like actually pretty chill
with it i'm actually pretty pleased
honestly
i also gave my eyelashes so it might be
a lady small
i feel like dragons are always beautiful
and have like lovely eyelashes
yeah dragons are the prettiest of
all of the huge uh beasts i would say
you know what i'm not gonna say that
because now i'm gonna get in trouble on
the internet
people already think i'm a furry why do
they think you're a furry in the
lion king episode i said that nala had
nice eyes
she doesn't shane just laughed really
i'm not wrong shane you're right
and that is time how do you think you
did
i think for the time allowed and the
complexity
of the scene i did okay all right well
let's send them to each other so we can
see what the other person did
okay wow wow
wow this is really impressive kevin oh i
love yours too this is
great but yeah it's really interesting
because like our styles are so different
too
that i feel like yeah my very like
wistful and like you know cute and then
yours is like
very dynamic yeah like yours could be an
illustration in the actual
book that's kind of yeah all right so
are you ready to do this
two more times i guess so oh
come on yeah i mean this will take this
will be a lot quicker so yeah
yeah 20 minutes on the clock and
go so i suddenly feel like i have zero
time
the nice thing is that we've worked out
the composition
and we've worked out all that kind of
stuff already so it's just almost kind
of like muscle memory at this point
it is but my drawing is already like it
doesn't look good like it
yeah mine is already a piece of crap i
can't even draw a circle
like i'm like i have no time can't you
just fake
can't you just make a circle in
photoshop okay all right
enough bashing
um okay so i've got a bilbo he looks
very little like my other one
well that's good i mean saying like he
doesn't look like him at all
oh that's bad yeah
i'm shaking my cintiq i'm working so
fast
you're having fun are you no crap
whatever oh i can't even stay in the
lines as i'm coloring
my kindergarten teacher would be very
upset with me
sorry mrs goldblack oh no
[Music]
oh boy you've got to leave whatever you
got to leave your cards on the table
yeah and that is time
ah perfect
well i'm glad you're happy
wow okay
that's not too dissimilar uh
but it's pretty crappy i don't know
i think yours is good too it's it's just
a simplified version
of your first one yeah i mean i figured
that was like kind of the move you know
it's like
it's gonna be pretty difficult to do
exactly but okay
so sarah yeah two minutes what's your
strategy
go real fast are you just gonna do like
a one color
thing i'm just gonna do line art all
right
here we go two minutes on the clock and
go i like how neither of us are talking
during this
because sarah this is awful
shut up kevin this is literally awful
all right
bilbo is done one minute okay well
see i think what you're trying to do is
do a good job and i'm not
10 seconds 10 seconds yep
that's time uh mine's a scribble
like it's literally just a scribble
mine's quite scribbly as well
okay all right at least we both know
what we're in for
[Laughter]
well yours is certainly closer to
to a thing than mine i think i disagree
i disagree the fact that you used
different colors
makes yours way above mine
okay so let's line them all up here and
what do you think when you see them all
next to each other
even though i did the most complex one
first
i feel like it does look like the
evolution of
an idea well thanks for drawing with me
sarah it was fun i had a good time
me too for a better look at these
drawings and more drawings from the draw
off crew
be sure to follow us on instagram and
twitter at drawoffshow
and we'll see you next time i hope we
don't get haunted by the ghost of
j.r tolkien oh geez you know i feel like
he's got other people to haunt before us
but yeah yeah he's like a peter jackson
it was way too many movies